you like me were um you know when you
see
somebody that you're a fan of because
it's like
you know i'm supposed to be you know
a comedian too which i am right but yeah
and then you're famous and then not
really but not as fun as
i'm not there at that level but you know
um and when you're around
you know those types of people because
i've been in a room
like where it's like i'm surrounded by
you know dana carvey all these [ __ ]
people right
yeah and in my own head i want to be
like holy [ __ ]
yeah but then no but you have to also
play the cool comic right so then it's
just like you're
you're trying to hide your excitement
yeah like so
so you say stupid things like um
what'd you do today why are you doing
robert here
over here yeah what do you mean
breakfast so you're funny yeah yeah
you think you're a comedian yeah so you
say some stupid thing like you know
[ __ ] at the sunset man [ __ ] traffic
remember when you really want to go yeah
who the [ __ ] right right yeah why do you
do why do i do that who who did you say
it to
every every time i'm around like you
know when i was at sebastian's house and
even someone like bill burr right i'll
like you know
try to be cool when i want to go [ __ ]
your last special so you know i mean
but normally i'm just like what what's
your kid's name
mine right mine was eddie murphy
wait mine was because i when i was 15 i
took my mom's credit card and bought
tickets to see eddie yeah at the
coliseum i saw raw
live wow yeah and uh
and we're at the coffee bean yeah and uh
and i see
the coffee bean and i'm like i walk up
to him
yeah yeah that's why i said at the
beginning of the show you do you know
how hard it is to give a compliment
yeah extremely hard yeah yeah it's a lot
of energy it's a lot of passion it's a
lot of fear
you don't want to meet your hero yeah so
when someone gives you a compliment take
it right because that's
energy it's good energy so i walked up
to him
and just like you right the worst don't
even know what to [ __ ] say
i look down and go i go uh mr murphy he
goes hey what's up man i go
uh my name is jokoya i'm a community
this is like eight years ago
or nine years ago i know i'm a comedian
wait wait raw was
25 years ago yeah okay and
i was also 15. okay oh yeah
[Laughter]
what happened nine years ago oh you ran
into it oh so what you're saying you saw
i thought you meant that you saw raw and
that same night you ran into eddie
murphy
no so you saw raw back just to finish
let me finish
so you saw raw and then many years later
you ran into
eddie murphy at the coffee bean yeah
yeah yeah yeah what's the story this
start over
i i'm on board i'm i'm not i need to be
i'm bored
so let me ask you something on board so
you saw anyways you saw the raw
i saw him yeah and i walked up to him
heart pounding i was so nervous i go i'm
comedian you're the reason why i just
stand up
yeah and then he's like oh wow man and
then oh he asked me
what's your name i go joe coy and then
he goes oh yeah
wait this was a long time actually this
is a long time ago this is like 12 13
years ago
he goes oh yeah i go yeah and then he uh
he goes all right
and it's just this awkward look oh and i
go i
i went to raw when i was 15.
[Laughter]
okay yeah bye bye
[ __ ] worst yeah [ __ ] worst
[ __ ] i could possibly i have an eddie
murphy story oh nice so
paulie goes paulie my brother and i were
at the comedy store
and i must have been i don't know if i
had mad at the time
it was before that yeah i was still
scared of people
right but i knew paulie yeah did
cedric's performing you got to watch him
i know i didn't know who cedric the
entertainer was
so i sit my brother and i and paulie sit
in a booth
eddie murphy well first of all i have to
pee too
uh-huh like real bad uh-huh you know
what i mean
and i remember eddie murphy and charlie
murphy was packed
they sat at the end of our [ __ ] table
yeah so you had eddie murphy wait you
didn't know who charlotte the
entertainer was
at the time i didn't you're kidding me
this is that long ago
late 90s right
they said at the end of the table right
and
my brother and i could we couldn't
really even watch that because we
we both went oh [ __ ]
you know i mean wait eddie sat at your
booth yes at the end of it
and charlie was on the other end i
didn't know charlie at the time yeah but
he looked like eddie and
i thought maybe they were empty is
important too but my brother and i both
i could see our buddies go
holy [ __ ] and they and they came to
watch sad
you had to watch cedric that's great we
don't and i had to pee
and i remember and they wouldn't move i
sat there for like 30 minutes
right p just dripping out of my dick
because you can't go
excuse me eddie murphy i've got please
you should have done that no no right so
you and you there's no way to go
underneath it
yeah so i just remember going oh [ __ ]
uh uncomfortable you know i mean it was
like so like
i had to pee but then also it was just
like a [ __ ] crazy
you know yeah yeah he's amazing eddie's
cedric are you kidding me cedric's
amazing dude he can't believe you don't
know who he was
shut up he was huge back then
but now joe you're getting to the point
in your career where
you're now at that almost at that level
of i am there